[Music]
what is going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are here to enter the
pizzeria for Five Nights at Freddy's
couldn't be more excited John are you
excited I am excited I've been in the
ball pit I'm stuffed with pizza let's
get animatronic ladies and gentlemen I'm
going to tell you right away that if
you're here to watch two dudes catch all
the crazy Easter eggs and
references you've come to the right
place get them all you are watching the
wrong channel for that I know like some
of the lore I've of course like played
the game like a little bit with Friends
by no means the experts that you guys
are going to be looking for all right
for the most part it's going to be
pretty new for us on all accounts you
know I see that critics are not on the
positive side but fans are loving it
let's see where we ride the line or
better sentences let's ride the line
pleas everybody all righty guys well
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also be sure to subscribe
click that notification Bell as always
full length R and watch along you sync
up with your own copy of Five Nights at
Freddy's we of course watching us on the
peock that is available for super sexy
rejects over at our patreon page we
cover several things exclusive over
there with the highlights and watch
songs included let's Swing Away action
[Music]
people security camera glitch oh how
much batter has
left what's interesting opening shot oh
he's trying to escape oh
goody it's time
spooky it really brought this set to
life damn yeah they at the celebrate
poster
monitors I love a good Eerie ventilation
claustrophobic
[Music]
shot come to security guard watch the
animatronics a man they're like in the
Next
Room
dumbass you deserve to
die awesome is that fox
oh hell
yeah yeah
buddy oh let's go hello security guard
this is
spotting sweet
sauce take Old Red Eyes oh I love how
this I love the design so
[Music]
far sprung in a trap nicely
put
[Music]
oo golly this is kind of Ian 80s horror
music sawes
[Music]
too Scott cin you never imagine the
Empire you would have now when you're
trying to make Christian video
games that
photo they're all here I love all the
drawings oh
cool nice even for my extremely limited
knowledge there's a lot of recognizable
imagery here mhm the graphics this way
be the perfect
Gateway
the 83
one it's crazy how this did start spring
from like a independent game into what
it's become yeah some guy
DIY Dream
Theory oh my god he has drawings
too come on let's go 5 minutes I need
you dressed that shot shows us this is
going to be from aby's point of view and
though the dreamer remains asleep he
walks through memory as if experiencing
it for the first time a new in the theme
stated cuz I don't want it to melt the
ice cream and can I get some whipped
cream on top and three cherries follow
your security instincts you want your
usual
right uh
yeah did you shoot this whole thing like
a dream in a way yeah we got this new
flavor
I think he's just grabbing his son I
don't think it's a kidnapping he's just
an Angry Dad
hey oh but did someone in his pass go
missing whoa whoa damn oh damn he just
throwing
down number 27 it was
2,000 he could be using this rage though
to take on animatronics drinking punch
pop while he does
it
y y here we go you ain't no Steve Raglin
liar liar you're a phony what is your
deal Mike would you some kind
of head
case you beat up a man in broad
daylight in front of his child who went
missing in your life it's like you're
not even trying here you sit before me
asking for help you know Mike is the
perfect victim I am just trying to
figure out who you are Mr
Michael
oh are they related is he Michael are
they going to go with it coffee sorry I
thought they completely changed it maybe
that was a hint that they are I'm going
to be brutally honest with you here Mike
given your track record your options are
going to be extremely
limited you know it's not that easy love
watching Matthew Lillard I have a job
for you come on sit
down I think the acting is great so far
though it's a security gig B disclosure
it's not great you get to Be Your Own
Boss sort of and you only have to worry
about one thing keeping people out and
keep the place tidy that's two things oh
he is perfect yeah he's perfect for you
want the job or not how's the pay not
great the hour is or he's had this
conversation before Oh many times I
can't do night
look like he's going to cry that's such
a
shame wait
uh Cas you have a change of heart is
Matthew L really tall or is Josh Hutson
really short Matthew Lillard is of
average height Josh Hutson is Tiny
thanks for
babysitting the loudest crayon that good
looking guy I recognize who are all
these other punks
my
friends are the ghosts of the children
communicating with her you know I
wouldn't be surprised this is a blem
house movie can you just eat some food
sitting on my
friend but you should know what happens
to little kids who don't eat their
dinners their bodies stay the same size
forever oh my God oh my God
foreshadowing it away yes when you're
compacted down inside of a machine my
friend says you're an idiot at least I'm
real oh my God for shadowing and
away he's listening to a Walkman mhm hey
man cassette tapes are coming
[Music]
back pining for
fun great transition damn how about some
burger with that ketchup on everything's
better swimming a ketchup like this
child POV they do a lot of the povs from
the children go watch your brother okay
okay his brother okay is it going to be
different from what I
remember
happens Garrett oh no go punch the
driver okay so he was
kidnapped that's the trauma he wasn't
watching
him the counselors weren't paying
attention Garrett
and now he's got to make up for it by
looking after Abby and every time he
looks at her he just sees him although I
feel like if I was shoved into the back
of some rando's car I would be panicking
a little harder from what I recall
Mike's brother accidentally got him
killed at that was the 83 oh yeah yeah
yeah where he gets bit by fredd the bite
of
83 but Mike's also the son of Aton I
have really tried to play nice I have
but I have to think about Abby now
enough is enough Doug oh he's fighting
for custody of her okay you know that
this is the right thing to do she
doesn't even care about Abby all she
wants is the monthly check from the
state when did Josh Hutcherson's voice
evolve into Aaron
Paul good
question you know pictures hold
tremendous power for
children images are the most important
tool we have for understanding the world
around us the creepier the better you
pictures mean something and who is at
the center of nine out of 10 of them
like it or not
you're her
world but what if it's not up to me
you're going to prove that through this
journey okay the camera that you saw
said 2,000 but this feels way older yeah
with a lot of it production design
choices yeah I was just calling to see
if that job that you offered was still
available oh it absolutely is no one
wants that job we had to change a heart
how soon could I start tonight yeah
buddy this place was huge in the ' 80s
with
kids been shut down for years the owner
is a bit of a he's kind of a Sentimental
guy I
guess he having so much fun just can't
bring himself to let it go
[Music]
yet yeah he is excellent it's just like
when you're getting briefed at the
beginning of the game and the ju the
position of their two performances is
wonderful security systems dated but
fully functional uh-huh lights on the
outside cameras inside and outside the
electricity is a bit iffy the
[Music]
cameras how great must it have been to
bring this set to life oh man people
must have been geeking out throughout
the
production ready to rock there's a
breaker in the main office just flip
it let's hope that comes in
[Music]
handy no
do not awaken the Beast just keep your
eyes on the monitors
and and keep people out I'll be right
B mom's going to so pissed at me piece
of cake is it
now uhoh the
switch it's aesthetically really neat I
will catch you on the flip side
hopefully the flip side
died oh you're clever you're clever with
your words my
friend God that look send another one to
his Doom I'm partially worried Matthew
Lillard's not going to be in it that
much more yeah I could see but I think
he brings there's so much presence to
his performance he's like playing it
just villain enough but enough where he
would have suspect he's up to something
yeah he seems like kind of an odd dude
welcome to Freddy Fazbear's pizzeria
where fantasy and fun come to life they
haven't been able to update this video
familyfriendly fun and cuttingedge
animatronic technology yes of course
enables our characters to interact with
guests in truly liike fashion while
cleverly
concealed nice let's introduce you to
the stars of the show the band
Yes yeah with the face
flash adorable aren't they did they cut
it out I love that that they don't even
even show up in the video first here to
Delight Dazzle and entertain for years
[Music]
to that's balloon
boy yes the last suit you'll ever
wear
[Music]
I love how that exit sign constantly
feels like they're calling to you get
out while you
can it's a very
[Music]
voyerism I don't know if it's the movies
doing or my knowledge of the game but
it's making me like not look at our main
character and everything
else definely who's lurking yeah which
of these murals isn't a
[Music]
mural
yes they're all here let's
rock cupcake
chica who's that uh it's uh it's Will's
Wonderland right
that's the creepiest
time take this one book with me wherever
I
go I keep trying to read dream theory
but I keep falling asleep whatever I do
everything's better swimming and
ketchup right M oh you going to save him
this
time they're all yeah what is
this who are you it's a lot earlier in
the movie than I expected it to be you
see what
happened oo cool did you see who took my
brother wait no interesting they're
immediately assing the personalities to
[Music]
them that's kind of clever tripping w
wake up but they are just teasing my
mind zigzags between like the first time
watching a movie and also like the
little things I know yeah totally I'm
like oh if I didn't know that would I be
like what's going on here who are these
kids or would I've immediately
Associated it being part of the
animatronics I mean you'd have to assume
that something is a Miss five creepy
kids and even in a dream cut to the
static on the
moners spark a welcome to sparkies can I
set you folks up with some appetizers oh
well that's no fun you do realize that
lunch is the most important meal of
Day game theory his voice sounded
familiar at first but know but it wasn't
thought it was breakfast some people say
that but you know it's just a theory a
game theory oh man don't ask me to
recognize any other YouTubers that may
appear don't worry Sniper Wolf is about
to show up be great yeah that's the one
we need he really needs this new job
look good on paper for the judge us
treacherous you deserve to die his
job is to make sure nobody gets in
so we get in oh my God we got victims
damn let's do this judge gives you the
kid and you give us
$2,000
1,000 wow it's all their want is 2,000
for that know that so cheap so cheap
like aim a little higher gang I'm coming
with you no no you're not I'm coming
with you why why do you want to go maybe
because he can watch her there and it's
probably a cool place for a kid in
theory a film
Theory she's got some mental spiritual
connection to the victims or
that night two the other thing is every
incidental character that shows up I'm
now like coffin don't remember what he
looks like I think if we just freak out
at everyone we don't write Rec we'll get
the job done yeah just never be specific
about who they are
yeah that looks like
Foxy or Bonnie I guess big
ears Garrett it's interesting that
changes in perspective each time too to
this dream don't run okay I I just want
to know what you
saw great lens help
me whoa that one kid's face the
blur
whoa
foxy there you go there's a
nightmare
it's
[Music]
time it's
me oh
good oh what oh oh no she's here to
explain that there's a history of
security guards that tend to go missing
or die you're bleeding by the way
you're flirting by the way a very demure
police officer I know where they keep it
for Save
kit that is a cut guess where that gash
came
from why
Nebraska oh you need a hand huh clever
cuz of the
hook Freddy's on my beat I like to stay
well
informed I believe you Al I really love
the place as a kid that's why I became a
cup I keep an eye on the old Freddy's
Vanessa
shell Mike Mary Shelly do we freak out
do we do we know
that just in case damn I can't believe
it she's really real you've been acting
suspicious since the moment you opened
the door uh well look it's been a weird
night and it's like a rainstorm in this
creepy old building with power issues
sounds like Freddy's oh sh she knows so
much more than she's letting on this
place it gets to people it's one of the
reasons why you're going to quit you
never
last does she think they all just quit
yeah I'm like what do have you not
looked further into that have you met
them yet or are you part of
it add to that the thing of there kids
going missing kids missing prepare to
have your mind
blown five children went
missing
awesome this this is the best thing
you've seen in your entire life yeah
definitely what I was going to
say want to
dance
[Music]
a no
maybe some other time show only plays
Once a Night you're a weird weird weird
cop my thoughts excited play this with
such mystery you said some kids went
missing back in the 80s what happened to
them it was big news that's why the
place shut down you're not up on your
80s headlines you're not even wearing
your
badge you're
marked well that was a very normal
altercation so strange don't let this
place get to you just do your job and
you'll be
fine nah uh-huh nah you're a ghost
you're the spirit of one of the kids or
some or another notable
character oh thank God we're finally
going to get some deaths let's do
it my Carnage my PG-13 Carnage yes let's
go maximum damage minimum
time oh yeah you see anything valuable
grab it good yeah golden yeah $200 each
here we come
man we'll be eating good for a couple of
weeks
boys oh those employees of the
month love the little cuts of the
security cameras showcasing creeping up
on
them
what game is on your shirt like Frogger
or
something oo
nice I actually missed it
first in a situation like this I would
always get another person yeah and then
we can both open the scary
cab oh thank God it's
nothing it really sets my nerves at
[Music]
ease
awesome cool
angle whoa the life
flashlight whoa
no let seat whoa don't kill not Anton
yelin
face
nice yes that was appropriately creepy
fun yes nice what the hell are you doing
cool it's well
Incorporated there's a child Soul
trapped in that door handle
come
on you went into the right
closet be there Clyde bye-bye
Bonnie
[Music]
o
Hank interesting they getting mileage
out of showcasing them it's interesting
cuz they they've like whoa all my game
tokens why did Jack so many tokens what
is the value of the that $200
cut work at any arcade get up the phone
in the screaming it's interesting yeah
that they they've taken a whoa that
they're making them like really front
and center it's like they've taken a
gradual buildup to featuring them but
they're not doing as much like teasing
and suspense and just showing them now
that they're here yeah it's not what I I
expected I mean they're the most
expensive part of putting this movie
together so yeah you got to
on that's a great
shot o yeah I mean the direction
aggressive POV
Punchy but reserved when it needs to
be do
they intentionally made the exit sign
look
pixelated
yes especially for the first big
sequence to be in the day is
interesting follow me don't leave the
getaway
vehicle this way oh it's just a video
game character want to help you this
way these eyes cry every
night
[Music]
warmer how in the
heck heck that's what the re-shoot to
make a PG-13 four the flip is going on
here
yes this is wise are you being lured in
or are you
just guess got to check it out got to
got to
investigate come
on bite do the
[Music]
bite hey that was that was that was a
surprising amount of violence for it's a
Nifty way to get your Carnage into PG-13
package I am GNA take you to
work
okay appreciate how exasperated he is I
am Desiring a little bit more Nuance in
their Dynamic yeah he's either just
dejected or they're being randomly
really playful yeah made a mess
sorry oh Dan James I hate her she's mean
and she smells like
cigarettes yeah I know it's nice that we
can finally agree about something yeah
are you going to give me away give me
away give me away give me away now like
that they dressed her like Olive Oil
from Popeye you're two whacked outs
remember to lock a freaking door you're
liable you wouldn't understand the
moment I file that report it's out of my
hands fall cops work this way so I used
to have a brother his name was Garrett
he was uh he was
taken oh was that what we've seen five
times
oh that's what that was been so confused
the whole time every single thing that
you see gets stored inside of you it's
called memory you just have to know how
to look I'd like to believe that and I
know that he's in here but he's just
he's it's buried and I go back to that
same memory and I I search for details
why don't you try to like do hypnosis
with like a professional I know what
crazy looks like Mike this isn't it a
you and Abby you still have each other
from where I said I'd say you're lucky
you're about to get even luckier when I
tell you what just went down at Freddy's
should
go yeah you're a cop who seems to waste
a lot of their time when you're at
Freddy's you stay alert what what what
about if he needs to sleep another
time come on Max come
on that's a sensible way to make it so
he has to take her to
work
not going to lie the critics made this
sound like this was like an egregiously
terrible film or something it could have
a bit more flavor but so far it's pretty
good yeah you're not here to have fun
okay slow down slow down slow down Abby
yeah some of the dialogue is a little
wooden it feels and like even in that
scene with her the cop I'm like she just
learned what we've known the past hour
yeah the main thing about this character
has just been vocalized wound reiterated
I mean in a lot of ways it does kind of
feel like the the Blum House movie
version you might
expect night
three
smudge
boy cool shot they emptied out the
prizes so she didn't file a report no I
suppose not I guess this place looks
cleaner than before they broke
okay I replaced all the
glass and now he's earned their respect
yeah because he cares for
Freddy's Abby you've got a new friend
Abby guess you really didn't need those
pills I would love it if this movie
actually kills her off it would be bold
it would be so cool child death child
death I know you're back
there
nope how they sound like cyborgs
yeah I don't know how it's possible that
you're
here like this in my dream but it's all
the electrical interference help me
remember the man who took my brother
love how we just accepted this if we
show
you what will you give us pizza Abby oh
Abby I'll give you anything you
want shouldn't have made it so vague
man whoa happy whoa oh my God not
wasting any
time nice
POV what do you think you're doing they
wouldn't stop tickling me said I was
going to die that's my
friend oh come on I want you to meet the
others this is a different direction
than I was
expecting they let the other ones be the
victims he's going to team up with them
Bonnie foxy and Chica what about cupcake
this is
Mike hi Mike this is a joke right I
mean there's someone here there's dude
your job got way more interesting it's
okay Mike I just want to
[Music]
play we have to go home now come on hold
on here's my home
address here's where to find us if you
need
anything had a lot of fun tonight thank
you for playing with
me very considerate young lady
yikes
[Music]
oh
bye I mean one part of me would have be
like this is kind of cool it's like
Discovery the teenage M Ninja Turtles in
away yeah I mean they didn't rip me up
they're they're you're hanging kept my
sister
entertained all right I need to go back
to sleep I got to get back to to that
clearing talk to those kids
again homie how are you not freaking out
and let's trying to understand what the
hell you just witnessed yeah you just
you just saw some unprecedented
just now so the kids have been
communicating with
her all the totems so those uh those
machines my friends does this guy only
sleep when he's on the job it seems I
feel like he should be sleeping now yeah
should be sleeping in the afternoon are
they ghosts of course else could they
make the robots move I love how simple
she has digested this kids man they got
the imagination you know it's it's a
whole different thing you know we used
to have a brother
right Garrett we still do I don't really
talk about him very much neither did mom
or dad who are the birthing lives of
these what a full on adult and she's
like like five yeah how long ago did Mom
and Dad disappear you drew that right
who told you about that was it a a boy
with blonde hair clearly ever tell you
anything about the man driving that car
I drew him who do you think took him oh
it's Matthew Lillard come on it's got to
be Matthew Lillard of course or the cop
I wonder if that's why the after name
stood out to him not the after name why
Mike's last name stood out to him yeah
whatever yeah I don't know if you just
recognized him from recognizing his
brother's last name because they're
obviously changing the background on
that yeah Mike is not the son of him so
maybe this is a way for him to tie up a
loose end now
yeah damn what the hell is her
connection to this Abby if I asked you
to wait in the car would you
no guys I'm back Abby hey Vanessa this
Vanessa cop doesn't do any actual
cooping nope I miss you
guys you knew about this I'm Vanessa
downtime cop it's a sleepy town you know
there's not much going on guess you
figured it out ghost children possessing
giant
robots how is there no like why isn't
anyone a little freaked out by the
reality of this and the fact that
they're just here just like yeah we're
we're I like the plot Direction but
there's something about the response
that's like making me a little bit like
what what the emotional dynamics of this
are a bit funky yeah I think we could
use the tables for the
fort
what is happening I like that it's a
misleading pleasantry yes that it's
capturing this like childlike Wonder to
it you know what I mean is he going to
like join them by the end and they're
just going to go around the country like
swallowing up bad people he needs to be
higher you did
it what are you
okay what is happen I like it in
here me
too fascinating I can feel this being at
odds with who to aim this movie at I
used to keep him back here for big
events remind me how you know
[Music]
that they tend to be pretty
unstable let's see
that's a spring of trap I think this
movie was just in need of a little
restructuring if they introduced this
earlier sure and this quality and then
you're like oh I guess they're fun and
kids in there but then oh wait no
they're Sinister then yeah the Sinister
evolves kind of like a Megan in a way
yeah no no yeah it's like do we trust
this a little bit no this is making our
lives better this is bringing us
together this is improving our
relationship oh wait they just killed
the other side of our family did you ask
them about this yeah I tried I don't
think they like me very much let's go
all you do is sleep well you don't try
to get to know them you need to drop
this I don't really see how that's any
of your business I'm telling you you
need to let it go how
how I mean they're baiting her in like
they want to they want to kill her yeah
they want her soul that's
wait talk to me I'm trying you're not
listening please finding the guy that
did this is the only thing matters to me
I mean Abby also matters to you yeah
Abby nah they're going to use your
essence for youth
juice that stuff's
called
Abby CH just Hing
over so
sorry
Remnant you can do whatever you want
with your own life but if you ever bring
Abby back here again I will shoot you w
wow seems like one of them was related
to her
yeah wow there's my favorite little girl
this is not dude you shouldn't have like
trap her like this I promise you this is
not what you think it is I hate you hate
you Mike not helping the custody case
yep
surprise
uhoh oh no they're going to turn on him
now when you do get back you and me are
going to have a little chat he gets back
you're going to have a little dead you
know what works for me a warm glass of
milk with Cam meal and honey I tell you
jeez
man what an there's some great
Sounders on and I think that guy's a
cameo that we definitely recognize oh
yes also Scott
cin study the
cameras I could use a little bit more
tension and suspense
yes it seems to not a heck of a lot of
that this movie doesn't seem like it
really wants to scare that much
attension doesn't exactly equate to
scary like it's not really what I'm even
asking for it's just put suspense you
want to feel dread I want feel you feel
nervous I want to feel something yeah
hey
buddy just stand there take in you got a
bowl of ketchup here for you this isn't
how it happened this isn't real memor is
rewriting itself
you want to save Garrett that's why
you're really here well to change what
happened of course to go back I can't
kid became precocious they're all gone
really so come live the rest of your
life in a dream you can be together with
him again like before but only here in
this specific scenario we want
Abby what's more important to you she
loves them you've seen her with them e
it's time to let her go
sweetheart you were never the right
person to take care of her he this is a
little twisted yeah I like to
see
okay
yes don't give the creepy blonde child
what it wants I can't believe he agreed
to that he's so driven by this no this
is wrong I don't want this
[Music]
this you leave Abby
alone see I feel like the most mood and
atmosphere comes whenever we're here
yeah isn't that awesome stay away from
my
sister and I feel like the direct oo is
actually more interested in this
yeah I wonder if this director has like
an Indi drama background or
something claw The Hook fighting D leis
from Gangs of New
York oh looking up at the trees
pining scoop let's go hello
[Music]
Michael you have wasted your life for
years is hunting down your brother
neglecting the sister very real beside
you well we escaped that pretty easily
yeah you just headed H the button you
know and just who right out found the
dead
bodies whoa that's a good gor
gag oh now it's becoming the trailer
yeah now first hour of this big trippy
sort
of Dreamscape
[Music]
film that humming always gets
me oh
nice he's always getting out of things
in the nick of
time what okay going
Offroad
Freddy Freddy's ability to travel is
incredible yeah why do you just stay
confined to the pizzeria it's time to go
play It's All For You Dam they just they
play so much more to like oh my God
already she fell
asleep how do we get there I play so
much more to the ghostly element than I
expected them to yeah than like the
actual murderous mechanical side they
did this mystery all in a weird
order that
guy oh my goodness
what why do I always get the
weirdos also a notable Cameo
woo when and doubt make a weird moment
funny yep instead of really
acknowledging that's the closest we I
think we've gotten to someone being like
this is disturbing they tried to kill me
vessa but I'm guessing you already knew
that yeah who are you brother you knew
about them too
right oh boy it's complicated more
complicated than possessed robots
murdering innocent people they weren't
innocent Abby is you don't know Abby are
you even a cup what do they want with my
sister they want to make her like
that yes feel like that was kind of
clear that's a great shot yeah come on
let's
go
I feel like this movie thinks it's doing
a mystery but the mystery is just so
freaking obvious
yeah like we're so L do the movie and
I'm like well yeah and if we just have a
Bas level understanding of the game like
I wonder what an expert is going to be
thinking about watching a lot of this in
the 80s when those kids went missing
police searched Freddy's from top to
bottom except for inside the
animatronics the man who took them he
was a very bad man nice lens FL
parents would cry and the police would
come looking and he knew there's one
place they never think to check
because why would
they because they're cops it's not just
their ghosts that are inside of those
machines they're actual physical bodies
is their
bodies he influences them somehow whoas
oh Matthew Lillard but it's too late now
he knows that you're looking for him
think you could have warned him more
specific way you need to tell me who he
is he is a very frustrating character
yeah he looks like this he's free and he
also gives people career
jobs is William Aton William Aton he's
my father oh snap there you go that's
why oh dang you knew not about Garrett
at least not when we met oh I'm so so
sorry tell me how to stop them tell me
how to save my sister I mean he wouldn't
know she wouldn't know would she I don't
think so I mean maybe but I don't know
if she's going to tell him she does
[Music]
know we use these for animal control woo
if he's there I I won't be any use to
you
spring
trp he really messed you up didn't
he he's a psychopath of course yes
clearly gave you your dead kidnapped
Brother's airplane to play
with I mean I guess like structurally
it's kind of just strange of like it's
supposed to be this bombshell of a
reveal but in the movie world we only
just learned about William Aton 5
seconds before she said it yeah so it's
not like a crazy twist you know I feel
like the bigger reveal just seems to be
like oh she's his daughter she's the
daughter of whoever is doing
this like they don't set up William Aton
earlier for that there's no buildup on
who he is for us to be like oh
diabolical you
know must have been
nothing
I love how these kids seem so freaking
normal but then they just behave like
let's just fulfill the roles of the
animatron yeah let's just wait here and
let's do our song and occasionally if
anybody breaks in then we'll Feast on
their souls and
flesh water use the element that brings
life yes CH where are we
going going to get you a new body
[Music]
okay time has been bought well done
chica I don't like this you
will get in kid
Abby it's one just for
you let me go oh no leave her
alone oh right in the
ey job hold done this guy's a great shot
he should have been a cop yourself yeah
serious eat this I've been stuck trying
to fix the past but you are the most
important thing in the world to me and I
promise you I'm going to do better have
this conversation somewhere else have
this conversation outside come on
so
creepy freaking cupcake it's the worst
one of the most yeah it's the freakiest
one it's the most DED it's like an evil
Pac-Man
no it's kind of a neat
shot the spirit descends the body
arises
that's a burnt
[Music]
cupcake just paint a big tunnel on one
of the walls like the Road Runner would
do run right into
[Music]
it foxy looks like starwolf
that horror movie
limp D Mike you are taking these things
down pretty
effectively uhoh hell yes let
go Aon has got to be in there
yeah o yeah I see some beard under there
yeah he's spring trapping it
[Music]
oh oh no oh it's okay
foxy oh she's still concerned I know
they're still our friends first I killed
your brother now I kill you yeah
symmetry my friend go to
hell wake up
children E I have something for you to
play
with nice stand up to your
dad little ones tell me you have a
sister she will love it
here you however are
finished that's
enough drop the knife he is the
creepiest one they saved him for last
and it is really
creepy
a you may have forgotten your loyalties
but I assure you they have
[Music]
not oh my God Stew's the killer the
whole
time secret sequel we both know your
you're not going to use a gun
oh devour him if you're going to kill me
put me in an animatronic the yellow
rabbit he controls them the drawings
they even did the EO
onio it's good we needed it you had one
job keep him in the dark kill him if he
got too close that's two
jobs that's all your whole thing man you
always say one job you give people two
jobs
yes Voodoo
crayons let go I won't let you hurt her
too
yeah that was nice that's
cool hey I bet she's still
alive
ooh what have you
done I have the power
now oh he murdered us they know
what you
did move move shining a light on the
truth look at you look at the nasty
things that you have become no you are
wretched rot little beast I made you
combine
yes o
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah this movie makes up for a lot with
great sound design too oh
yeah good becomeing yes I always come
back of
course he does play unhinged
extraordinarily
well cuz he's a psychopath but you could
hear the hit to the former debonaire
kind of quality that he used to have you
know of the wealthy man yeah the showman
who would be responsible for something
like
this whoa
it's interesting that their eyes become
red when they've learned the truth and
been set
free Freddy's just crumbling and then it
just crumble yeah crumbles into the
Earth I have a prediction what the turn
she's taken these past few weeks balloon
boy is going to show up ah I bet you're
right the only one small enough to be
everywhere what do you want for dinner
pizza or spaghetti good thing they
killed the ant yes solve one problem
yeah completely freed us of that burden
we're going to make a quick stop okay
and no one's investigating that murder
andessa I don't know if you can hear any
of this she's dreaming now yeah fall
asleep next door I don't think that
either of us would be here today if it
weren't for
you even though you did lead us pretty
well into danger so get
better I love you we're a family
now you okay no no why why would you put
that up there can we visit them sometime
you know what you never know what can
happen this movie could be a hit maybe
we could get a part two do you think
drinking up and know if you just turn
into a cow could open that sister
location
yet
oh
that is
Eerie game
over what an interesting
movie
oh oh I think this is a yoav song yeah
Living Tombstone Liv tomstone that's
what it's called that's what it's called
yeah this is huge for them damn that's
awesome first thing on the credits not
bad there's got to be a
postcards oh no oh no my dude not today
sorry do you live in this car this poor
man I said re
the balloon
[Laughter]
boy that was pretty good balloon boy
coming to play
okay guys if you are listening to this
on Apple and Spotify
we just watched Five Nights at Freddy's
literally just finished watching it and
we are going to talk about it right now
most death and I got to say like one
thing that I was loving when looking at
this is wow what a great merch
advertisement yes you know what I mean
most definitely and then I thought about
like just how great the real rejects
merch has been as of late reject Nation
sh C and yeah so we're wearing like two
the RR apparels right now but then we've
also got some great ones like we have
the space babies of the Galaxy we got
the Child Protection Services recently
launched America's ass and then we also
got some Ahsoka inspired te's as well
and a whole bunch of other ones we got
some Last of Us inspired ones thank you
to all who have been purchasing the RR
merch is ones that we are creatively
involved with ourselves and so it means
the world whenever people well go
because it's one of it's one of the
absolute best way to support the channel
it's my favorite way for people to
support the channel personally so it's
pretty cool it's pretty cool wait for
that day where I see a tea in the Wild
on somebody who's not any of us yeah and
then they don't know the what real
reject wa for for them to be like no I
saw somewhere in the shirt and I wanted
to buy it so I went to the
store know who influences the
influencers you know you didn't even
know reject Nation shop was something
tied to some YouTube channel just always
felt like a reject in the nation that I
live in so I bought a bunch of real
reject shirts specifically but I didn't
realize there was a channel I don't know
why they spelled the real world I hate
reaction videos I don't like boies
really can I return this but I really am
rejected by most people I mean um all
right well John um yes what' you think I
thought this was a strange and
interesting experience you'd be nice man
there a rabid fan base out there they
will tear you limb from limb closer to
that the games are like that what the
movie will do some kind of
gearbox yeah uh I no I mean you got to
kind of respect it a little bit like in
the sense of that I understand fandoms
can be very sensitive they've been
wanting this for a very long time oh
yeah they clamor at the bit for it and I
understand that you know they they're
probably wants to eat this all up way
more yeah and and so yeah what is your
take on it factoring that in no totally
I mean this definitely also be extremely
on sugarcoat your extreme hesty your
authenticity I thought this was a very
fun movie
experience uh it's not what I
expected it's it's definitely a strange
movie however I can't pretend like I
wasn't Giddy and and enjoying seeing the
characters come to life spending time
inside of Freddy's and just thinking of
the promise that this property has you
know beyond just one movie um yeah this
is in some ways like the blumhouse take
on Five Nights at Freddy's that you
might expect the execution is like kind
of peculiar and curious to me uh and I'm
you know kind of I'm excited to kind of
bat it back and forth with you right now
but um as it stands I'm not 100% like
that's exactly the experience I was
hoping for but at the same time it was
always intriguing no matter what and
sometimes it was being effectively
creepy and uh and you know nodding to
the games in ways that were obviously
very fun uh and in other ways I was
scratching my head a little bit as to
like what the true intent was and what
was
maybe uh more Twisted before like I
think the thing is I think this movie is
in kind of a strange position because I
think it has to play towards a very wide
age range these games are rated teen it
has a very dark Grim Twisted lore that
lends itself to an R-rated experience so
I think this movie's impact kind of gets
muddled in between all that um but I had
a good time
regardless I don't think this movie
needs to be M methan no I think it's I
think in terms of an actual movie it's
not a great comparison I do I do think
though that methan is a PG-13 blumhouse
film yes it is that did it exceptionally
well and didn't feel to
PG13 even though it works way it's like
when I was watching this sometimes you
know you might watch something you go
you start rewriting it in your head and
you're thinking about what you would
have done differently and I don't re
when I was when I say that I'm not even
thinking to myself what would I do to
rewrite it in terms of here's what I
would change about this character here's
what I would change about this character
that's not that I would really I'm like
I would just kind of rearrange the
placement and unveiling of how a lot of
it was done so it could actually be
effective because for the most part I
didn't really feel much tension I I
didn't really find it exciting I didn't
really find it suspenseful it and it was
kind of like in intermittent
yeah um it wasn't that funny not that I
was like walking in expecting a laugh I
I just I I do feel that like it nor is
it nor do I have strong feelings about
anything that is egregiously bad you
know like that yeah it's neither
especially good nor bad I found it to be
very very mid to a high
low with
an occasional like honestly like the the
parts that I thought saying the most
were a little bit more The Oddities that
were not advertised um like like some of
the dream moments perhaps I mean I I can
imagine how that feel you know and and
was was strange to me is like for the
most part the the lore that they
explored did not mean to rhyme but maybe
I got more when talking about the lore
let's open up the door and see what's at
the Freddy store Okay so the at the um
now now now I'm so caught up in what I
just did that I don't remember talking
John please
stop stop me somebody stop me
um before my thoughts wash theore uh
what we talking about the unexpected
part these parts are not cut up John we
need to remember the unexpected parts of
the lore you said were things that were
more oh yeah no uh uh actually well no I
mean what I'm saying is not even
unexpected it was it was that I mean the
only thing expect it was like the
Vanessa thing which I don't think is
part of the actual lore uh I I doubt
because to my
recollection it's uh Afton has two kids
and Mike and his brother yeah and then
brother is the one who dies in 83 yeah
Mike Plays this trick on him and then
yeah gets mangled up by Freddy yeah yeah
so they really obviously change that
right got make him sympathetic and then
um and then you had them killing after
and then there's a whole thing with like
a William and I think the other guy's
like it's not Hank I think it's like
Hank or Henry some other guy who
partnered up with partner yeah they had
like a after those makes his
animatronics his robotics company and
all that my point being is that most of
the lore that like for someone like me
who doesn't who would be like don't ask
me I'm I'm still like no actually kind
of was aware of most of what they
explored here yeah yeah if you have a
friend like i' I've got a couple friends
who are very dedicated and and immersed
in five nights and through them over the
years I have been exposed to a lot of
this stuff and and so it was enough for
for me to at least grip most of what was
happening yeah so none of it was like
unexpected lore or surprising or
something I haven't heard before already
so my my point with that is like in in a
way it could it could have also played
to M and I I wouldn't I wouldn't tout
myself as like one of those I'm not by
know means a super fan or or some big
fan of like Five Nights at Freddy's to
the point where it's going to naturally
play on some type of rency or Nostalgia
for Five Nights at Freddy the way how
I'm hearing it's plating to people out
in the in the cinemas when they're
watching it and they're like freaking
out about references and things tied in
and oh my God they brought they
translated it from animation game to Big
you know uh uh I'm I'm thinking just in
terms of like an actual movie that they
that they made you know and I think for
as a movie that they made I thought the
trailers were way more exciting and and
when I talk about the placement of stuff
I have no issue with anything that they
actually threw into the film uh I I I'm
saying like I think it would have been
more effective with just a rearrangement
of a puzzle like like honestly the first
act before he gets the job and
everything leading into when he gets the
job like fine don't change your thing
yeah like that's all great like that
that's all really great that that was
when I was like I just setting up mic
it's it's it's solid setting up mic I
like what they changed with Mike's
backstory I think that you got to get a
protagonist who you could care about um
like and then they what they did that I
thought was great and it was the odity
that I really loved was
when Abby is bonding with the
animatronics and is really getting along
with them and it's like kind of
whimsical and a little peculiar
a little bit of a fantasy now and it's
and it's like this is an unexpected
bonding and this is not at all what you
what you sort of think of when you think
of Five Nights at Freddy's yeah and I
thought that is where I would have kind
of placed that earlier I'm talking about
just a rearranging of scenes you place
that element into the movie earlier and
then it's like maybe there is something
kind of cool here and then there and
then him and then they're actually
bonding with each other because there's
this whole thing about custody battle
and and where should they go and like no
I could be a dad look she even likes my
job and then the break-in happens yes
Breakin happens and she's there you or
something like that I don't know who or
or well they break in they both away I'm
not saying like I'm I'm literally not
saying change anything other than the
placement of it they break it they break
in and then when they break in that's
when you see them do something horri
side yeah that's when you see them do
something horrible and you start to
wonder about it and then you could have
your dream stuff like slowly being in
inter related and then the kids come in
later and this movie had this weird
thing where they were like leaning so
heavily into the Supernatural ghost
elements first and foremost at the
Forefront and they did no real like
mystery shrouding with the animatronics
like it seemed it got to the point where
they just sort of dropped that kind of
early on and they just put them like
front and center so some of the
placement I thought just you would have
achieved I think a lot more of the
atonally effective stuff that I was that
I personally subjectively was craving
sure um if they just rearranged some
stuff it's kind of like if if when
you're talking about methan for right I
don't know why that's the one that just
keeps coming to mind because I think
that having that scene with Abby bonding
with them made me go well that's what
myrian did right was making you have the
Wonder with it and the bond but imagine
if MRI was just like she's evil right
away and and then they tried doing that
they'd be like this is stupid and and
and I think here and then yeah cuz there
was like responses that just felt like
not real human responses to things that
I thought were a little no one seemed
that rattled by the fact that there were
a bunch of yeah living animatronics just
kicking it and doing Whimsical stuff
yeah the guy gives them the ride still
and I'm like I mean you could pass that
off as like maybe he thinks it's a
costume but it's just so strange that
you're like we should have some other
greater acknowledgement of this yeah
because even the scenes themselves I
don't think are NE like like when I'm
looking at okay what do we need in this
scene if if if I'm like looking at an
index card of like what do we need in
this scene I'm like okay yeah that's
fine so maybe some dialogue changes sure
um like I think the dialogue definitely
could have used a puncha for some rework
sure a little more flavor and I'm trying
to say that like the actual integrity
and the castle on which they are built
that house on which they are building
this is actually all fine it's really
they have everything they need yeah yeah
like when I and and sometimes it's just
a a phrase when I'm saying like no
actually it's literally just I think
this would have been way more effective
if you just rearranged the way you
unveil your story yeah totally because
then you might be able to a just ring
some different tones and more
disconcerting energy out of all this
stuff and you could also maybe generate
some suspense and some actual payoffs
because the other thing is the the way
the events are presented in this order
it does kind of I think you said it one
point it seems like this movie feels
like it's trying to sell you a mystery
but like the way it's actually
presenting the information isn't that
mysterious and doesn't really lead you
to having too many burning questions you
can't already assume the answers to even
I think if you don't know the story I
mean they really established the whole
dreams thing and you know the the five
kids from early on and they each have
little totems that you can pick up on as
to you know their counterparts as the
animatronics and stuff and and I think
actually Megan is not that bad of a
touchstone because if you look at what
that movie is it's a you know younger
person thrust in the position of being a
single parent to a kid that they're
emotionally distant from and now we have
animatronics filling the Gap there but
oh no something is wrong with that uh
and with that one you just have you know
an AI where is this you actually have
ghosty so like it it does feel like
this is perfectly within blumhouse's
wheelous and it does feel like the kind
of drama they tend to present it is like
accessible it's not crazy specific or
unique but I think through the acting
but it's not scary it's not and it's not
suspenseful really and it's it's Eerie
in
moments it's not at spheric or any
there's nothing really about like here's
the thing is what I'm saying is nothing
about this really made me
go how would I put it sometimes you
watch a thing where like the fan base
loves it because the fan base loves a
prior and then they're going to watch
this and then they're going to eat it up
because finally it's being brought to
life yeah this did not really do
something for me that made me want to go
and explore the the lore even more I did
not mean to do a triple rhy
so it's bar but do you know but do you
know what I mean yeah this this doesn't
yeah present you with some kind of
deeper well of mystery you feel like you
just scratched the surface of this
presents you as something that in its
again current form and iteration seems
pretty easy to kind of solve and figure
out and nothing really it it's weird
there is like a flatness about it and
it's like I thought it was pretty slick
I liked most all of like the shot
composition and even the the editing and
stuff I thought was generally fine and
the performances are pretty good I think
Josh hushers is other than a couple of
weird Direction choices with how to re
react to a couple of things uh in
certain moments I think for the most
part he gives a really great performance
I think he's a great a great actor in
this and I think Matthew Lillard is is
also extremely I think he's excellent
yeah I think the performances are really
solid of them two yeah and it's it's I
guess that's the the most damning thing
about this movie is there are so many
good pieces and everything here even the
stuff that is kind of boilerplate or
familiar the stuff that is less about
the specifics of the game Ln more about
like ah it's a movie so we got to you
know give you these emotional eyelines
and stuff like there's something in that
where yeah it never really
Rises to anything and everything yeah
just kind of starts to feel like it's on
one Plateau the entire time so it's kind
of it's like a pleasant experience and
it's occasionally strange but it's yeah
I I don't know there's no pulse to it
yeah and it's lacks life and I can't
find what the origin of that is because
I I guess you'd go the direction and I
thought like in isolation there were a
lot of fine directing Choice like I
don't know what else this director has
done and part of me was wondering like
oh yeah is this the kind of person who
who has directed more I don't know
thoughtful horror or or just independent
dramas or something cuz yeah at one
point again you you seemed you pointed
out the uh vibe that like oh these parts
in the forest were were dealing with the
actual familial trauma is seemingly what
the movie is most interested in and is
most invigorated by when it's presenting
you know its energy and execution um I
it's it's it's a strange one to look at
because there are so many things that
are like pretty good to find about it
and yet it it just it doesn't like yeah
I don't know it it it packs a really
light punch nor does it build up and
it's like I don't think weird like it
was predictable and the plot the plot
turns and the the mystery unveilings
were really predictable and obvious and
uh yet other than the vessa think sure
just because I didn't know what the
they were doing with her performance I
like I I that was such an odd involved
somehow it was so oddly done the way uh
you know uh and it wasn't it was more
like just tell me what's going on more
than what is happening with her like who
is she it got it just reached the point
like just you're you're you're actually
frustrating so just tell me like that's
that was the effect that I had with her
um yeah because I hate women yes
especially women in positions of power
yeah well and two I guess there's the
other thing that I guess should be
addressed because I don't know how I'm
sure really quick I think we should
interlace it with something more
positive so we somewhat balance
sure sure even though we're not going to
do ourselves any favors with it you know
it just sounds like we're mocking it
with the way I'm introducing well I mean
it is the animatronics I think the
animatronics are lovely I think they
really brought it to I think
aesthetically they really brought they
really brought Freddy's to life
aesthetically they didn't they nailed it
they
did mood-wise not really but well and
there is a thing I again I didn't hate
this movie I'm not trying to bash on it
like
it's yeah it's like a very tepid
positive response for me but I will say
like having I was playing the game again
last night uh oh were you yeah yeah I
got the five pack for for uh switch so I
was just like kind of you know just oh
yeah cool so just getting in the mood
and I think as good as the animatronics
look and as Faithfully as they are
rendered here they are scarier looking
in the digital Realm whereas here they
actually kind of have the opposite
effect where I'm like well they're kind
of endearing they're kind of cute but
that's why the placement if you put that
stuff earlier that could work then it
works draw you in and then you get it
and you get Abby's perspective yeah yeah
and then Mike actually can see a good in
like learning about oh my yeah I wanted
a little bit more I think they could
have done a little bit more for their
relationship as characters something I
would to Chang in the writing to yeah
like most of what you get with Josh
Hutcherson is this one core memory this
one trauma and yes I only I'm so wrapped
up in in in my lost younger brother that
I feel responsible for that I'm
completely neglecting my actual present
sister like you know you could you could
have played more with that but with the
drama there yeah and and I guess what I
wonder because early on I was thinking
to myself okay we've seen especially
Wily's wonder I haven't seen Banana
Splits but there are other movies that
do this and I know Wily's Wonderland had
to have had them kind of up in arms in
the office I would imagine going like
well how do we make it different from
this and early on I was thinking like
okay cool you take it yeah really lean
into the supernatural make it more like
a blumhouse ghosts type of movie in some
respect and there you H have an
opportunity to not have to do the high
octane action disturbing but like that
movie for its rough edges and be movie
qualities does have an intensity and
does have like a bigger scare Factor
coming off of the animatronics and it's
funny because I don't think that these
two couldn't coexist and I think it
really I think I think you've ultimately
kind of uncovered the the main thesis of
what's not working here and I wonder why
they positioned the events that they the
way that they did because even in times
when I was flashing back two Willies
watching this they would take it in a
different direction where it's like oh
yeah the animatronics are just coming
out cool subversion we're just seeing
them we're putting them on the screen
we're not doing the the quisite suspense
buildup that we all would be sitting
there going we know these are evil and
blah blah but there's also kind of there
doesn't seem to be a whole lot
underneath the subversions no that they
put here no there's nothing they're just
kind of in the immediate moment sort of
disconcerting and then you're like oh
okay well well this is odd I I I just I
guess I didn't feel an an enthusiasm
behind the camera for this one I really
didn't I felt like it felt kind of like
when Marvel hires an independent
director
to do one of their movies and this was
sort of the Imp and like and that's not
what I associate Blum House with I feel
like Blum House sometimes their failures
come in the form of they didn't do
anything to rain this person you know
like that or or I mean you'll get your
ones that are at least purportedly like
super boiler plate like I guess TR Truth
or Dare or Fantasy Island but this this
doesn't I didn't get the impression um
damn that is uh oh a woman directed this
movie cool no wonder we we're not
feeling strong about it's our sexism
John that's right our sexism for this
movie still starring a dude is it a
person in color so we could come across
racist on top of that too oh I don't
know I don't know no doesn't look that
way unless she's white passing who knows
oh thank God okay we're just so she did
a Blum sex not racist thank God if you
got to be one you know it's a lot more
understandable yeah on the internet did
interet you can be sexist but you're
being racist and it's hard to get away
with that sexism is a Cornerstone of the
internet Community okay oh yeah no men
invented the Internet of all Races but
they were men I think women sometimes
try to do revisionist history here but
uh sure no men invented it so okay she's
done a a Blum House into the dark
special and then some other things that
I'm not as familiar with I'm going to
guess like this looks like you know it
looks like she's got at least a bit more
uh docu and dramatic background some
horror as well this not the first horror
thing she's done but I feel like this
may I I don't know I thought there was a
confidence behind she do a movie about
the Dust bow I guess so A Plains woman
faces the harshness and isolation of the
untamed land in Western cool I've always
wanted to see like a horror movie in the
turn into dust bowl well dude watch the
wind I mean it might be I I would be
curious to see this director's other
movies because when I saw her name pop
up at the front I was like oh I don't
know this person but this seems like a
neat choice and this is one of those
things where we live in a time where
there are more women getting directing
gigs but they I think often are for like
women's pictures we got to name some
women directors we like to balance the
scales okay Jennifer Kent is amazing
Jennifer Kent the invitation is one of
my all-time favorites ological horror
movies uh which is not Jennifer Kent is
not it's not Karen Kus the invitation
yeah is Karen kusama yeah oh wait no
who's the one who's made Seven Samurai
in all the great films Tashira mafud or
no uh kir
kirawa yeah my favorite woman director K
carawa uh there is K Cawa yeah Emerald
finel or uh or Katherine I mean
Katherine Bigalow is a Titan oh my God
so we not sexist thank Goda loved her
remake of Candy Man sure looking forward
to the Marvels as well you know like
this is American Psycho was Rectify Mary
Haron yeah good call O uh Tamara Davis
all right good we're not sexist we've
proven our
point I feel like I would be interested
to see like I want to
know what led to this person directing
this movie not in any way that I think
it was a bad choice because I feel like
so much of was happening in the
construction of the movie and behind the
camera was assured and had some flare
and some you know oomph um and yet just
the this presentation of the story like
I don't know this is such a huge
property with merchandising and you know
a game Legacy and it's taken on this
whole huge life and part of me is like I
can see this very much being a movie
that the producers are like very
involved with and modulating and
tweaking along the way uh I could see
how this might not be in voice you know
a good calling card for a director
versus just in construction or something
like that yeah so I'm watching we're
watching the wind trailer right now
without any audio
on and this to me does seem like more of
like this looks like a distinct Vision
calculated perspective this is just from
the trailer I'm getting and definitely
more the person who would make the dream
sequences and it would be the person you
get to do your F your animatronic movie
yeah I mean I don't want to be that guy
I like I like blem house fans of the Bob
du and the witch are likely to fault
like that I couldn't help but think that
if this had been a 24's Five Nights at
Freddy's this would be this director's
movie yeah and I feel like this director
was a solid a quality choice for a movie
like this perhaps are you still bitter
towards Blum House no I like Blum like I
feel like in general Blum House well
yeah and I mean we we all get into why I
don't anymore but but no I've been a blo
housee fan for a long time I like a lot
of their stuff I often gravitate toward
I know they have their fair share of
Misses but generally I see Blum House
and I'm like yeah let's do this like I
anticipate a blem house maybe not 100%
as much as an a24 but but I I like them
both you know I they get a lot of flak
for some reason they've produced as like
a lot of hits for the amount of flack
they get yeah people go like a fing
thing well that often can be good you
know I think I to I tend I've been
interrupting you an awful lot today I'm
sorry I I tend to get a lot of
flak uh I I tend to like a lot of their
films that even get a lot of flak is
what I'm trying to say well yeah because
I think there is you know what I mean
John what's my opinion
uh no I I think that I would agree
because like there are yeah some are
more inspired than others but a fair
amount of the of the more like mid tier
blumhouse joints are ones where I'm like
yeah this could be more unique but for
what it is it's perfectly serviceable
and when they are going for that
mid-range of the audience sort of
Blockbuster thing with some of their
horror movies I'm here for it you know
I'm often here for it and I'm absolutely
willing to give them the benefit of the
doubt and this this marriage seem like
one that makes a lot of sense pop
culturally and where blumhouse is aimed
in terms of their overall demographic
you know I think they skew younger um
than maybe like an a24 does but uh I
don't know yeah this this felt like it
maybe got lost in a No Man's Land of
like what audience are we supposed to be
for because some people really want this
to be an R-rated movie and it could
easily be that and some of that stuff
with the you know the mask and the
woring gears just like a Saw movie or
something
and yet I feel like they made a horror
movie kind of for almost nobody except
for like the youngest people who like
this game I don't think you needed the i
i n none of it being R-rated as like I I
have I have no issue with that at all
honestly like I think I think just the
context alone is you could do in a PG-13
movie it is unsettling and creepy you're
murdering children transferring their
souls and controlling them after their
death like that that alone with the
imagination and the context is R-rated
enough in its Vibe you know the same way
the games are rated teen but they have a
very mature level Twisted lore yeah and
that that's all you need so like even
like the way they had that one person
who was like let me look inside this
Freddy mouth uh that that like the way
that death went down and then and if the
movie leaned a little bit more into like
the way how the games would do a bit of
the POV of of mystery and a little bit
of shrouded or obscurity or fre like
turning the lights off frequently yeah
like if they if they lean a little bit
more into that when it comes to the
violence then you can even get away with
stuff that might seem more violent than
it actually is so there I I had no
qualms at all with it being PG-13 and
even experiencing this I was like nah
there's nothing really here that
happened I was like this should have
been R-rated um and we already have that
movie you
know well I mean the thing about Five
Nights at Freddy is like when people
compare to willly wonder is that Five
Nights at Freddy's is is exceptionally
really into the like when you really
dive into it is so much about its
history and the ghosts and all and and
and like the transference of Souls and
and all that stuff whereas Willy
Wonderland is a little bit more direct
about like what it's advertised as and
here I I think this movie um kind of
seemed a little disinterested in some of
the actual for initial appeal and then
went full Supernatural Coast movie and
and then would like remind you about
animatronic stuff to the point where it
becomes a bit confusing when you're like
is this place evil or is this not quite
evil it was especially became confus and
that's what I mean like it needed some
Wonder um it did it it lacked wonder and
and I think when it got confusing when
it was like they spent so much time with
the ghosts of the kids that I think they
should have dialed some of that back
it it I'm not talking about the dream
like if you kept them just like that in
the dream world totally cool but I'm
talking about in the actual physical
world when you would see them as ghosts
yeah make it less clear that that's
exactly what is going on yeah yeah and
and to the point where I was like why do
they just like act like typical
animatronics at times yeah if they're
living in these things and and they can
kind of do as they please kind of always
I get it when there's somebody inside or
whatever and they're doing their thing
but like the rest of the time I feel
like things could be very different for
them and what are they what are they
doing you know in these long stretches
where like nobody's there you know yeah
and if they can go into these dream
worlds and stuff why don't they just
hang out there all the time because why
the would you want to hang out in
this goddamn boring ass Pizza this
animatronic body and I think they could
have I think they they needed something
bold for this and I feel like they I
expected something out of the whole
dream thing beyond that I mean I like
the concept of like oh yeah your body
remembers everything you've ever
experienced and so somewhere buried in
there is the memory that you're looking
for however I feel like you could have
and he's taken the medicine and he's
sleep deprived already like you could
have done some reality warping or
something like that to really disconcert
us and to throw us off and to and to
yeah get us questioning like okay am I
just conflating these kids with these
animatronics or something because you
know the power of suggestion your
brain's crashing things together like
there there's so many opportunities for
disconcertion and confus Fusion that
they didn't really seemed interested in
taking yeah yeah definitely yeah I mean
yeah movie's a bit repetitive with the
dream like like the dream stuff was like
I get the whole point is he's repeating
this but I I you get your kns built in
but uh yeah yeah but same time it was
like G does just get to a point where it
feels were better yeah yeah totally yeah
he just needs some other element of
flavor like if we did it like three
times and then you get a little further
into the memory each time and then
suddenly the show up that's what I mean
instead of introducing that so early and
then the kids show up you're like whoa
what is this you know well yeah cuz it's
interesting at first when you're seeing
the dream and it's different a little
bit each time but then once he starts
meeting the kids that kind of goes away
and he adjusts to it in a such a
everyone casual manner so Cas that's
what I meant by the ghost thing if he's
just like you're the kids who died right
ghost I don't know how is this happening
but I have a little goal here like that
would make
he should have had like a moment of
like wait who the hell are you guys I
would doubt my sanity if I was in this
character's position with the obsession
that I have and then seeing these kids
and then being like wait a minute
animatronics and waking I'm taking these
Dr like part of me it was thinking like
okay like maybe someone's going to be
like oh it's these drugs man you're
seeing things oh no wait it's not yeah
uh or if he was wondering is this one of
the things I didn't remember are these
kids being here I involved with this
yeah instead he kind of just Tak is face
value it's like who are you entering my
you know yeah and uh that was that
there were that's what I mean just like
it feels like they wanted to reduce
Peril and yes that that is the problem
with it is like they they got the
information across and like I said I'm
talking about like little tweaks I'm not
saying big big like these little things
make major differences yes but I'm not
saying do a major difference on any of
this stuff I'm like you know just T it
emphases here a little bit more reaction
here change the placement up and you got
the pretty much this just a re-edited
movie yeah well and people get finicky
about kids in Peril but I feel like this
actress seemed certainly capable enough
I think you could have again for yeah
it's a pg3 this a solid PG-13 movie I
think you could have presented her more
situations of peril or something
especially when things start to turn
sour because some Stakes of the deaths
yeah cuz it even when they're killing
you just know that the four of the PE
the guys who break in you know the other
family members who are trying to you
know mess with him and and you know get
him fired you know what's going to
happen to them and the movie seems to
know that you know that and and yeah
there's there's no real sense of danger
despite how twisted and Grim all of this
is it's weird it's like somebody telling
you a really harsh story but with like
not a lot of vocal intonation yeah well
let's rate it John Let's rate and call
it a day I rate it a
6.7 fair enough damn that's high I would
give it like a six um I think that uh I
like the production design a lot I think
one thing I wasn't expecting was to be
like didn't expect to like Josh
Hutcherson's character as much as I did
uh I and it's really elevated by his
performance Matthew Lillard I wish he
was in here more really enjoyed him a
lot great uh I I think while the
animatronics could have been captured
with a little bit more mood and a little
bit better buildup I love how they
brought them to life yeah um there was
some great sound design in here and all
in all you know like I think the movie
could have felt exceptionally more
convoluted than it actually is you know
like that that is one aspect to this
that I think it could have been so
bogged down with just non-stop
Exposition and they managed to not get
overly carried away I would say yeah
with it you know I was like PE the
people have made the the the the history
and the backstory and while I know they
changed some stuff sound like an
intimidating Prospect to land into like
oh you're you're opening up like a whole
you're going to have to at least watch
like a three-hour video to get part one
to understand the Five Nights at Freddy
and and then so I thought this might be
a situation like that when I was hearing
some like I didn't I didn't feel that at
all like I think they managed to make it
digestible so I there's there's lot to
appreciate but at the same time I do
think that there's a a lack of mood a
lack of atmosphere a lack of tension
it's not scary I don't it's not feel
like a weird Twilight Zone episode it's
not fun and fun it's like intermittently
fun like there's a moment that can be
fun and I mean like a moment not even
really a whole scene yeah uh it it's
there there was nothing unnerving about
it like I don't really know what genre
this is it's it's kind of a it it nor
does it feel like a an interesting
splice of genres to me there's a lot of
things about it that I I don't really I
I didn't I found myself becoming more
disinterested as it went along and then
they'd be like oh it's a little thing
happened here that was intered and then
I it would go right back to well they
two steps forward like it would be like
one step forward two steps back is how
how the experience kept going for me
yeah and so yeah at the end of the day I
I have to be honest with myself and be
like I know that there's a lot of
massive fans when it comes to this but I
I would give it like just a six out of
10 and a lot of that six is mainly for
like the effort for everything that that
they get right barring the actual like
emotional experience of watching it cu
cu yeah like in closing I guess like if
it's absolutely fair to compare these to
the games and I think the games what is
charming about them is you have this
crazy ass lore but the immediate moment
of playing it is all just about the
suspense and the the you know kind of
butterfly tension of like oh God who's
lurking and when are they going to pop
out of me there's not even jump scares
really in this movie and and looking at
this this has three story by credits and
three writer credits one of each is
Scott CN and the director also has a
writing credit I I almost feel like this
got sanded down in drafts and and became
what it is so so yeah not a great
adaptation of Five Nights at Freddy's
but like also not terrible just just
fine I'm almost I'm tempted to give it a
a flat 50% like a like a five out of 10
I'm more there but I'm more there for
effort because I can understand
like the the the part of it is
that like putting a you I think at the
end you should just judge a movie based
off whatever the final product is yeah
absolutely um I'm G to judge it based
off the treatment I do have I do have no
I'm saying that like yeah having some
understanding of the lore and then
seeing some things they had to change
and then having to adapt something like
this is no easy no that's a that's a
difficult obstacle for something like
this it really is and I could see it's
easier for us to be in this position and
look at what we're what we just watched
and here's what we would have changed
but maybe some of those changes were
happening as they were making it when
they were realizing well this isn't
working this isn't working so we so
maybe this was indeed the best thing
they could do at the time because you
you have to deal with scheduling you got
to deal with production you got to deal
with a whole B like there's a whole lot
of things that I can imagine were
working against it that maybe this was
the best they they thought they could do
as they were trying to change it to
thinking about some stuff um uh but no I
mean overall as a as a final product
like literally the six is for effort but
if on on just an emotional thing I I
have no real strong emotions about what
this movie did for me so I I am
emotionally like a five you know yeah
just like lukewarm tepid it's yeah I
feel I'm actually I would say I'm
disappointed by that like I have no dis
I have no real strong feeling and is
this is something that were you your
main job was just to make something fun
and exciting yeah this is the kind of
movie where you can SK if you get a
couple things right you can skate by a
lot of other things and this is the
weird experience where it gets like a
lot of things technically well crafted
and yet
misses the one like even one greater
element of whatever suspense fun Etc
could have made this you know the fun
you wanted it to be yeah whereas here
yeah you're left with like God there's
so much good work and this all could
have worked really well however you know
yeah yeah yeah at the end of the day uh
a little disappointed with it uh at the
same time I'm like my mind's also going
it could have been a lot worse could
have been horrible yeah it's weird and
it doesn't yeah it's it's such a funky
movie because it doesn't feel I don't
even feel like angry about this I'm just
kind of like ah this could have been
more I I I I am so very Resolute is left
me in a resigned apathetic mood of just
like whatever I don't really give a
that's where that's where I'm at okay
what's next yeah you know yeah I don't
there doesn't leave you with much to
chew on I don't think I'll be ruminating
on this experi but somehow we talked for
like 45 minutes well sometimes it t it's
this kind of movie we like what is it
what is it about this that doesn't work
somehow we live landed into the longest
discussion we've had in a very long time
yes and there's only two of us so it's
okay this is an important cultural
moment it is we'll have a tight 10 when
we watch The Exorcist of
[Laughter]
believe um all right guys well what did
you think about this movie uh did you
love it as a film uh what did it do for
you uh leave your thoughts down below
and uh hey we'll talk with you all soon
thanks for being
here all right John what's the theme all
right all right we're going to shout out
all of our super sexy $10 patrons with a
Halloween party theme and uh We've
entered everyone into chat GPT so it
knows all your identities now it's going
to come up with costumes for each of you
based on your name they'll either be
something funny scary or uh it'll be
movie related something like that so uh
so here we go I told chat GPT to keep it
snappy let's do this let we're going to
react to it in real time we're going to
react to it all right here's a fun
Halloween party shout out for your super
sexy rejects say chat GPT all right we
got namari coming into the party namari
the night walker from a lost episode of
The Twilight Zone you get to look that
up for yourself the CV gun 123 he's the
possessed VHS tape from The Ring PR wi
that's actually pretty invented it's
pretty fun we found what CH GPT is good
at rewind at your own risk Mike Joyce
Mike the killer jukebox Joyce every song
he plays fortells a horror tale that's
great that's awesome really great
okay
FY seur Scissor Hands the Lesser known
even more eccentric cousin of Edward not
bad not B that would be Charming that
would be funny Ryan Smith as Ryan the
reanimated straight out of
Frankenstein's lab oh cool Count Adrien
Tims count Adrian from Hotel
Transylvania a bit more fashionable
though perfect real nagas as a snake
charmer who accidentally summoned the
serpent from the Black Lagoon W there's
like Back stories to these guys this is
so great Heather gear Heather headless
horsewoman that is inventive yes
haunting the streets of Sleepy Hollow
Dude the alliteration today Ian that's a
great one I got if any of you dresses
these selling
capability pictures a good suggestion on
hallowe costum I'm going to ask what I
should be this year cuz I always have
trouble deciding Ian Simon Ian invisible
the man you feel but never see how do
you do that that's a pickup line right
there how do you beat the invisible s
High Glover the s High siren her songs
Le zombies instead of sailors oo I like
that there's just stories to these guys
actually you do an invisible you get a
shirt with a collar up above your head
and then you just get a wire and put
some glasses seen people do it pretty
good pretty clever you wear gloves uh
hey we got Kayla King Kayla the king as
Kayla the pharaoh's curse disturb her
tomb and face her wrath sexy yeah that's
good and you can depending on your race
you know appropriate some cultures there
Allan Ling and as Allen the alien from
the movie They Live Among Us
oo all right it's just movie character I
should watch that movie I like how this
decides between like you are just a
movie character because of your name or
we're going to give you a whole
backstory cuz there's not a new movie
character yeah this is just who I think
you are so I'll make up a character
based off of that uh Hey Kier dressed as
Kira the Killer Clown pennywise's
competition clever dude cuz there's got
to be someone dressed as Pennywise at
the party so you can challenge Eric K 39
Eric the Extraterrestrial he's not from
around here beautiful he's got a
catchphrase let's let this be the last
one Nick X Nick X The Exorcist got
demons call Nick that is so smart that's
mag all right put it away we'll do the
rest on another video I don't want I
want to like reacting to these in real
time move the window John right in front
of me my be my be my be guys thank you
for coming to our Halloween party if any
of you dress up like this seriously take
some pics and uh we'll share them
somewhere and uh we love you be well you
guys thank
you